Jim what's up buddy this is not funny
why is my stuff in here wow that's weird
oh dollar first stapler that's pretty
good yeah well I'm not paying for my own
stuff okay I know you did this because
you're friends with the vending machine
guy who Steve yeah
oh pencil Cup
oh no no no no that's my pencil cup
um I don't think so I just bought it uh
I think so and you're gonna hand it over
to me I love these
oh there it is J1
apparently I don't know how many nickels
seriously we're gonna set in the back uh
yeah that's the safest part of a car in
the event of a crash driver always
protects his side first
thank you sir well thank you I never let
anyone walk behind me seven out of 10
attacks are from the rear okay well that
still leaves a 30 chance that I'll
Attack you from the front uh yeah but
it'll be easier to stop I can always
block the blow or I can counter it with
it
uh yeah I just got my replacement credit
card
you want the number oh it's uh four
seven nine three zero zero three two
three three one three
security code is nine two seven okay
great thank you very much bye
so do I did take the bait
use my credit card numbers to send a 200
bouquet of flowers
to my wife
from me
[Laughter]
stop it stop what you're talking about
me in Morse code
you know what jokes on you because I
know Morse code
that's what we're doing
and are a very limited free time and
with our very limited budget we went and
got a nanny and then we went out and
took a class on a very outmoded and very
unnecessary form of communication just
so we could talk about you in front of
you
yep that's exactly what we did
it all started when Dwight was tapping
his foot against the leg of his desk
when I asked him to stop he said I will
when you lose the baby weight
very well I must have imagined it I
apologize
detonator
Detonator where are you finished with
the sketch yeah
hmm doesn't seem like the type uh
Phyllis got a good look
um
I plan on Plastering this pervert's face
everywhere
you can run but you cannot hide
Thunder muffin paper sex predator
hotline this is Dwight Schrute hey
Dwight it's Jim
Jim what are you doing I'm busy
no you're not I'm looking right at you
don't
have information about the psych
predator
you have information about this ex
I saw him two minutes ago
in the women's bathroom above the sink
anti-flashing task force
above the sink
Pam
since it is your 15th anniversary at the
company I thought it might be
appropriate to begin the festivities
with a 15-minute Round of Applause I
like it followed by a 15-minute moment
of silence I don't know
is it classy enough Jim enough with the
classy okay I just feel like after 15
years of this company Bravo by the way
that we should celebrate with a very
classy event a night to remember I think
you're right this party has to have all
the excitement drama and Intrigue of my
time here and of course
classy and classy yeah Michael
you're just agreeing with him because
he's wearing a tux don't you see what
he's doing here last week Dwight sent
out a memo about the dress code so this
is me showing him that I'm taking it
very seriously
[Music]
zombie
in your hair
sorry
[Music]
are there any messages nope
foreign
[Music]
large tuna have you seen my cell phone
device
no because someone is calling right now
there is a call
fine I'll just go sit at my desk and be
quiet
sorry I annoyed you with my friendship
[Music]
excuse me
and I'm also sorry
that a lot of people here
for some reason think it's funny to
steal someone's personal property and
hide it from them
here's a little news flash it's not
funny
in fact it's pretty freaking unfunny
Time Thief Time Thief fire him do it
you've really never stolen any company
time never you are a thief of joy
hmm
yeah four seconds
what are you doing
oh you had said that you don't do
anything personal during work time so
I'm just making sure
oh wait a minute so you're gonna time me
every time I yawn that's absurd
really
oh hey look monkey knows how to use a
stopwatch everybody he's to
personal conversation 17 seconds
there is no way that that was
one second
Andy
you
by any chance did you see Battle Star
Galactica last night no I do not is that
any good actually not it's really so-so
okay
I mean like all the crazy monsters and
stuff you know like Klingons and Wookies
and
all that but
sorry it was there's something you
wanted to add anyway
is that anything like the original
battle sorry black dude you know what's
weird
it's practically a shot for shot remake
really
huh cool
story is kind of bland it's about this
guy named Dumbledore Calrissian oh who
needs to return the ring back to Mordor
really
that doesn't sound right everyone has
called me Dwayne all day I think Jim
Halpert paid them to
yes
five bucks each and it was totally worth
it this morning I found a bloody glove
in my desk drawer and Jim Halper tried
to convince me I committed murder I
think he may be the real murderer Jim
Halpert said there was an abandoned
infant in the woman's room when I went
to save the child I saw Meredith on the
can
okay
this morning I knocked myself in the
head with the phone
that actually took a while I had to put
more and more nickels into his handset
until he got used to the weight and then
I just took them all out every time I
typed my name it said diapers
just a simple macro
you know
these actually don't sound that funny
one after another
but he does deserve it though by the end
of the day my desk was about two feet
closer to The copier
yeah I just moved it an inch every time
I went to the bathroom
and that's how I spent my entire day
that day
all right